look it is no secret that first person
shooter enthusiasts
are constantly changing their configs
whether it's your sensitivity aspect
ratio resolution
video settings or your freaking view
model it often feels as if our
settings are in a constant state of flux
as if screwing up a single frag is
enough to
overhaul our entire preferential
infrastructure
from the freaking ground up but there is
nothing that gets subjected to as many
endless tweaks as our crosshairs
big small thick thin
large gap tiny gap dynamic
transparent outlined or just an absolute
monstrosity
reticles mark the one aspect of our
config where there aren't only an
inexhaustible variety of options to
choose from
but quite literally too many
combinations to count
the question of course is are crosshairs
really as cosmetic as we all think they
are
or just changing them as frequently as
we do
actually hurt us more than help us
[Applause]
okay so first things first for all of
you league of legends enthusiasts out
there
what is a crosshair a crosshair
is the default or custom bespoke reticle
that sits dead center in the middle of a
player's screen
and allows them to well aim direct
gunfire
and go clicky clicky boom boom that's it
seriously this one's super
straightforward
what may not be so straightforward is
why people
obsess over them so much you see back in
the earliest days of fps
crosshairs were extremely uncommon sure
you could stumble upon them in certain
arcade games
but when it came to the titles on which
the first person shooter genre was
actually built
wolfenstein 3d doom even goldeneye
there was nothing you literally had to
intuit where your shots were going to go
in fact it wasn't really until half-life
came out in 1998 that crosshairs became
a thing on pc
and even then it was tiny transparent
impossible to see
and well ironically exactly the kind of
thing that kids these days would
consider
a god crosshair here's the crazy thing
though the first competitive fps to
really usher gaming reticles into the
modern era
wasn't actually on pc it was on that
accursed casual infested hellscape known
as
console what was it well
it was uh god i can't believe colton's
gonna have footage of me saying this
it was halo you are
damn right it was halo combat evolved
was ahead of its time in basically every
area and that includes
theoretical the centered crosshair
helped ground the player
since they were able to freely look and
move in any direction
which was still a new concept to 3dfps
gamers in the early 2000s
especially on a console the crosshair
told you not only where your gun was
pointed
but also how that particular gun would
fire like the large circle of the
shotgun or
small hollow dot and scope for the
sniper rifle
oh you thought i was done bragging about
the most revolutionary fps ever made
they let me talk about halo guys we're
just getting started
when placed over an enemy the crosshair
will turn red
only if the player is in range for aim
assist with that particular gun
missing all your shots like me
zooming in extends the aim assist
distance of any gun with telescopic zoom
later in halo 2 a small dot was added to
the center of the reticle on precision
weapons when you were aiming at your
enemy's head
maybe put a little more respect on the
og halo scene demitri
story of halo when i mean when there's a
story to tell
jesus that was brutal now
when you think about it it actually made
a ton of sense for halo to put such an
emphasis on having a baller crosshair
the release of halo was
revolutionary from a multiplayer
standpoint inspiring an entire
generation of gamers to take up arms
against one another in what was
undeniably one of the most formative and
foundational pvp experiences
across the whole of esports i'll never
forget this i get like a headshot
on zack and i'm like sit them down and
there's like applause
and i turn around and there's a group of
people who are watching
now they get it the multiplayer was the
the thing
[Applause]
of course pioneering as it was halo
still offered a
fixed immutable crosshair you couldn't
change it even if you wanted to
it wasn't until the early 2000s began to
unfold and
one fps in particular started offering
tools to rework reticles
that it became clear people wanted to
the advent of counter-strike both
inspired
and enabled players to start tinkering
with their reticles as obsessively as
they do today
as the professional scene became more
prominent players began
copying their favorite competitors
configurations
including their crosshairs i mean back
in the days you need to find those weird
websites like similar today's where
there's websites specific for like
configs you can download the pro ones
and even
semi-pro ones and those things and you
can also find like different
sizes and different colors on it of
course things
really began to escalate with the
release of cs go as
crosshair customization became even more
intricate
from size to color to alpha to outline
to movement and recoil correctives
crosshairs quickly cemented themselves
as the most easily scrutinizable
component of one's config
the one thing that you could fiddle and
fuss with all the time
since well it was cosmetic
right as it turns out kind of
you see while the makeup of one's
crosshair and the merits thereof may
indeed be subjective
the concept is not in other words
on-screen reticles carry an immense
responsibility and it isn't just to let
you
pop heads in the most seamless way
imaginable it's to prevent
motion sickness or well technically it's
called
simulation sickness since you're not
actually moving but
yeah same idea here to explain this
phenomenon is dr
madison klarkowski an expert in human
computer
interaction who teaches at the
university of saskatchewan
the leading theory on simulation
sickness is that it's just a result
of sensory conflict as you said it's
this separation or the
incongruence between what you're seeing
visually what you're hearing
and you know what you're actually
experiencing in terms of your inner ear
balance right in terms of the vestibular
system
and having that crosshair in a video
game this provides this nice
stable point of reference it's kind of a
reminder to
you know your senses that no you're not
actually doing all of these things that
are being stimulated you're
sitting in your chair you're sitting on
your couch you know you're actually um
grounded in this in this very real
physical place
now this is something that game
developers have struggled with
for years if any of you are familiar
with virtual reality kits for instance
you'll know that they're likely to make
certain users hurl
seconds after popping the headset on
i feel like that polygon journalist
douchebag who couldn't complete the
goddamn tutorial or cuphead
oh kicking my ass go
[Music]
stealth mode activate that said it's
hardly limited
to vr i found a really interesting
tidbit which was that the developers of
mirror's edge actually conferred with
ballerinas
about preventing sickness when they're
doing pirouettes
and they discuss the concept of spotting
which is keeping your eyes fixated on a
stable point of
reference and that's kind of what the
crosshair is
is a replacement for it's that stable
point okay so we can all agree that
having a crosshair is important and now
possess more than just a
cursory understanding of what function
it serves
see what i did there but the question
remains what makes one reticle
better than another is it all a matter
of preference or
is there truly some kind of god cross
hair well in an effort to find out
i actually consulted with another expert
one who actually makes a living by
flicking to faces and well
[ __ ] destroying them i'll give you a
hint his interests include playing
counter-strike on a starcraft
sensitivity
generally resembling a 3rd grader who's
sitting down for his school photo
and being a bonafide spinbot who boasts
better spray control than the sprinkler
on your front lawn
elige i asked north american
counter-strike's resident cutie pie
whether he thought there was actually
such a thing
as a perfect crosshair and to my
surprise actually
he said he thought there was his
i think that i did find the perfect
crosshair and i actually haven't changed
it since
i think 2017 or maybe late 2016. it's
been
years since i've changed this crosshair
and i just think that it's perfect
because it's like a color that
i can just see on everything and uh i
like that it's a draw outline 0.5
because it kind of gives me that outline
but it's also not extremely ugly where
if you have the ally thickness at one i
don't know i just think that i have the
perfect crosshair for that
but that's to be expected right like
doesn't everyone think that their
crosshair is the be-all and end-all of
bopping kids is there really a sense in
which eligius is like
objectively better or does it kind of
all just boil down to
what kind of player you are and what
game you play in valor and for instance
the
only other esport in which all of this
crosshair talk is really relevant
there's this emerging theory that
smaller more surgical crosshairs are in
fact
the tech why well because you don't
spray
nearly as often as you do in cs go and
need to focus on
well one taps
you disappoint me one enemy
[Music]
you also don't need to memorize smokes
in valorem so there's no need to make
your crosshair
big enough that it helps you execute
lineups and
if and when you do decide to start
dishing out turbo virgin sova arrows
you can just make use of your actual
user interface
and then i would place my left diamond
right into this light bulb like this and
do a one bar
and it's gonna look like this revealing
area so what this one does
it reveals garden but it also reveals
people that will stand here so you can
actually assist your team peeking from b
what this has resulted in of course is
some traditionally
big cross-haired boomers such as former
competitor and
fps educator extraordinaire nothing
to rethink what reticle feels most
comfortable when playing valorent
i think i use a smaller one just because
you're not spraying as much and i think
it's two main reasons one
you're not spraying as much uh you are
encouraged to shoot smaller bursts and
move more and kind of dance between
shots a lot more
and then two the game's more colorful so
i feel like i see the crosshair a lot
better
in valorem just because everything is so
vibrant around the map i just feel like
it's easier to see it
yeah i think overall it's just the
shooting style
encapsulates the crosshair kind of for
me in ballerina here's the thing though
you don't
just see these tiny ass crosshairs and
valorens
take the homie rops for instance not
only is mousesports a star fragger one
of the only top tier professionals to
have always kicked it in 69
but he consistently runs what is pretty
much the tiniest [ __ ] crosshair i
have ever seen
the result is a literal speck that has
somehow earned him
two consecutive spots on the hltv top
10. so how is it that rops uses this
thing to such great effect
well according to dr karkowski it could
be that he's just
so well versed in the intricacies of
counter-strike that he doesn't need any
of the other bells or whistles that
other reticles bring to the table
so there's something this concept in
pedagogy
it's called instructional scaffolding it
concerns a gradual
shedding of assistance by a teacher the
teacher can be obviously like a human
being that is a teacher that's you know
helping you with the task
in this case i think it can also be the
crosshairs when we get to those really
really tiny crosshairs
um and we start to lose maybe a lot of
the benefits that a crosshair can
provide because instead we just have a
single
cyan pixel or a single pixel that is
almost entirely
transparent we may find that those
players um
are it could be a personal preference or
maybe they're just better able to
compensate
for those micro circadic movements or
for you know
thrift or for you know a lack of
orientation maybe they're just able to
or willing to compensate for that
in if that means you know a reduction of
a tiny amount of visual clutter
there's also the question of outline
movement and
alpha to consider which along with size
seem to create an
inverse relationship between precision
and visibility there's this thing called
microseconds and micro secades are
a involuntary jerk-like movement of the
eye
in which your eye just kind of your eyes
naturally drift to
a nearby point of interest and by
providing this crosshair
you actually um limit the tendency to
drift
to another point of interest whether
that's involuntarily um
or not there is research out there on
what you know the ideal fixation point
in experimental design might look like
and the ideal central fixation point of
shape that they found was one that was
very similar to a crosshairs like
crosshair bullseye blend
and that was ideal in terms of uh
reducing the frequency of those micro
circadic movements
in other words the bigger more outlined
and less transparent your crosshair
becomes
the easier you'll be able to see it both
as you flick it around and as your eyes
wander elsewhere on the screen the
problem is that a
bigger crosshair can also be
hard to hit [ __ ] with while it's true
that you won't ever lose
track of the damn thing having a big
bloated well-defined reticle can also
make it more difficult to perform
careful precise exacting frags
especially at longer distances what this
does is force players to engage in a
balancing act of sorts between the
things that make a crosshair
noticeable and the things that make it
well usable
and it's because of this that they fall
prey to what might
actually be the single biggest pitfall
with crosshairs
our tendency to change them it feels as
if
every day you see streamers competitors
community figures or just your everyday
enthusiasts
either tweaking their reticles or
rebuilding them from the ground up
hell esl even went so far as to produce
an american
psycho-inspired skit parodying this
phenomenon
new crosshair
what do you think
that's very nice look at that
gave it a go yesterday one in the
thickness
zero on the dot and one on the outline
it's great for visibility
the question of course is whether all of
this fiddling is actually doing more
harm
than good whether the real problem with
your reticle
is your inability to pick one because at
the end of the day if you're changing
something
all the time how can you possibly expect
to master it
i've like changed my crosshair maybe
once over the last four years
and it's like that's it i have never
changed my settings
throughout being pro and i i think it's
a very bad idea to change your settings
unless you feel like
you really need to do it the reality is
that crosshairs have kind of become
so widely regarded as inconsequential
and
nipped and tucked so frequently as a
result
that they've kind of become the go-to
thing to
scapegoat whenever a frag goes awry
because
chances are you didn't whiff your shot
because you opted for a 0.5 outline
instead of no outline at all
chances are it was you something you did
or better yet failed to do i think
people only change their crosshair a lot
of the times because they think that
it's oh it's just a crosshair every
single time but i think that
around that time when i did decide to
use this crosshair
that was the time i was like i'm not
changing this anymore if i ever
miss or mess up it's my fault and i'm
just gonna keep with what i'm at
and it helps me focus a little bit more
and focus on what's really important
so if there's one takeaway from all of
this crosshair talk
it's this while it is true in some sense
that your reticle is the most
cosmetic feature of your config that
doesn't mean it needs to be the most
chaotic
stop fixating on how to improve your
crosshair
and instead start focusing on how to
stick with it
since at the end of the day it's the
player who makes the crosshair
not the other way around i knew i had to
work in
oh i forgot i'm sitting on the green
screen i can do the elise photo
just incredible i have a version of
dimitri elise photo now
it's perfect